While Marvel films just seem to get bigger
and bigger with every passing year, Black
Panther continues to stand above its contemporaries.
A record-breaking success, a pop culture phenomenon,
an Oscar nominee for Best Picture, and a film
that shattered barriers across the world,
this 2018 superhero movie was about as artfully
designed as comic book cinema could ever hope
to be.
Black Panther packs in enough world-building
for an epic fantasy trilogy, introduces dozens
of memorable characters, adapts multiple comic
book story arcs, and sends the audience home
with a powerful, socially relevant message
that can't be forgotten.
Before Black Panther was a finished film,
though, it was a script, a camera, and a whole
bunch of scenes that needed to be strung together.
Editing is one of the most underappreciated
aspects of film production, in general, no
matter how good your material is, keeping
the pace tight means being ruthless about
which scenes matter and which don't.
Hard choices are required.
In a 2018 press interview, director Ryan Coogler
said that there was one scene in particular,
set in the wake of T'Challa's apparent death,
that he was, quote, "incredibly proud of,"
but which he simply couldn't fit into the
film.
Now, Coogler talks this scene up for a reason.
Set in the Wakandan citadel, high above the
city, it depicts Okoye and W'Kabi in a tense
verbal confrontation over Killmonger's takeover
of Wakanda, which has resulted in T'Challa's
apparent death.
The two of them, both loyal to Wakanda above
all else, are split in regard to Killmonger's
goals.
Aside from the phenomenal acting by both performers,
this scene also showcases the characters as
individuals, as leaders, and as two people
in a relationship.
"This is what you would have me leave the
Dora for.
To bring our children into this world where
they become conquerors."
"Yes."
In an interview with The Wrap, Black Panther
editor Michael Shawver, described this terrific
sequence as the one scene that was most heartbreaking
to cut from the film.
He recalled,
"Toward the end, after things go bad and Killmonger
is in control and all that, we're talking
about, what are they going to do?
What is Wakanda going to become?...Those are
two powerhouse actors and it was an incredible
scene with so many layers to it, boyfriend
and girlfriend, it was general and her advisor,
all those things.
That was painful."
That said, both he and Coogler agreed that
it had to go.
As Shawver put it, film editing requires being
hyper-aware of moments where the audience
might lose immersion.
"At that point in the movie, it's about two
thirds through, and that's when most movies
drag.
Ours was taking a while to get to that point."
The Okoye-W'Kabi scene wasn't the only great
moment to go splat on the cutting room floor.
Shawver said,
“There’s a scene between [T'Challa] and
[Zuri] which sets up their relationship.
It sort of lets you attach yourself to their
father-son dynamic so that later on in the
film…you really feel more."
Coogler and company also made the tough decision
of cutting a great emotional beat between
T'Challa and his real father, T'Chaka.
This scene is a flashback, set immediately
after the events in the opener, wherein T'Chaka
kills Killmonger's father, N'Jobu, and it
shows T'Chaka back home in Wakanda, telling
a younger T'Challa of a difficult choice he
just made.
"Some choices are harder than others."
"I am sure you did what is right for Wakanda.
You always do.
You are a great king, papa."
The young boy proclaims that when he grows
up and dons the Black Panther costume, he
will use his claws to ensure that his father
never dies.
There's a lot of great foreshadowing here,
and the scene does help establish how the
roles of king and Black Panther aren't quite
synonymous.
Still, you can see why it got cut.
Nice or not, there's nothing critical here
that isn't established elsewhere in the film,
and deleting this scene allowed the narrative
to get back to the present day much more rapidly,
at a point in the story where pacing is particularly
crucial.
Either way, every movie has to make cuts,
and Black Panther was no different.
But Coogler and company can take pride in
having such high quality and emotional resonance
even in scenes that didn't make it to the
big screen.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.